"American Horror Story" is never a show
that shies away from the potential for
controversy. From its inception in 2011,
the FX horror anthology has consistently
pushed the envelope and forced viewers
to confront some of their deepest fears.
While "Coven" is typically regarded as one
of the most beloved seasons of the show,
it was still full of many moments that forced
fans to stop and consider what they were watching.
The witchy third season indulges
in campiness alongside the horror,
but also included many genuinely uncomfortable
moments that made fans squirm in their seats
for all the wrong reasons. There were plenty
of not safe for work scenes that got to fans,
especially because many of them veered heavily
into lurid and exploitative imagery. There are
also several graphic torture scenes, where
people lost body parts in terrifying ways.
"Coven" stood out just as much for its
occult themes as it did for gory scenes.
On the show's subreddit, one user
asked fans to share what scenes
they found the scariest. One fan
jokingly called the show "American
Trauma Story'' after scrolling through
all of the frightening scenes. However,
one scene from "Coven'' came up multiple
times and stood out among the various answers.
We actually wonder how Reddit
managed to narrow it down to just
one that went too far. The mere idea of
Madame Delphine, played by Kathy Bates,
systematically removing the toes of a gardener
who had the audacity to come looking for a
bandage makes our hairs stand on end. There's
also the self-imposed punishment of Cordelia,
where she decides that she can only gain The Sight
by destroying her own eyes with a set of garden
shears. If nothing else, it's a great excuse to
never do any work outside in the near future.
"My blindness gave me real vision,
but it's of no use to me now. Not when there
are witch hunters right outside our door."
While we're on the subject of eyes, we can't
forget about the big murder moment for Myrtle.
The next time you get a craving for fresh fruit,
try not to think about the time she scooped out
the eyes from the sockets of Quentin and Pemby.
It's bad enough that she extracts these from her
two victims while they're still alive, but
she took it a step further. Thanks to one
of her concoctions, Cecily and Quentin are
completely immobilized during this impromptu
surgery. They can still feel every agonizing
moment while Myrtle revels in her revenge.
We could spend hours dissecting the brutal
moments throughout "AHS: Coven" that make us
want to reconsider ever attending a dinner
party involving cocktails with garnishes,
but there's only one that will
haunt us until the end of our days.
In keeping with many fan criticisms of "Coven"
that have popped up in retrospectives of "American
Horror Story," several Redditors pointed to the
opening scene of the season premiere as being
particularly difficult to watch, although
we would say that's putting it mildly. The
episode opens with real-life serial killer Madame
Delphine LaLaurie hosting a party in New Orleans,
where she is punishing one of her daughters
for trying to seduce a Black houseman. In
truly sadistic fashion, he's the one who
bears the brunt of the punishment. What
follows is one of the most horrifying
sequences in the history of "AHS,"
transcending the horror genre and hitting even
closer to home in today's cultural climate.
The sadistic socialite brings the man, Bastien, to
the attic, where it's revealed that she keeps many
others in a makeshift torture chamber. Delphine
cruelly mocks her abused captives, calling them
her pets as they watch in horror while Bastien's
head is covered by a hollowed-out bull's head.
He whimpers while she says he's to become a beast,
since he acted like one, citing her inspiration as
the mythological Greek minotaur. The head is then
bonded to his body, completing the transformation.
Fans agreed that the brutal, grotesque scene
went too far, with users claiming they almost
gave up on the rest of the season due to this
opener. Despite staying on the air for a decade,
it makes us wonder how many potential
"American Horror Story" fans have checked
out thanks to the plethora of shocking
moments throughout the show's history.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.